[Music]
it's hard to know how you can change a
prisoner's mind or plan and the reality
is you can't I mean a change has to come
from within that person and sometimes
that change only comes when you have the
experience or that person has the
experiences themselves
so again harking back to my old days of
working with the Communists in in
communist China there was some really
there was some horrific things taking
place with Mao um during the Great Leap
Forward and the Cultural Revolution but
before that time even there were a lot
of atrocities that didn't get heard
because if you talked about them they'd
kill you so more open and Western
Approaches the government there was a
lot of criticism of the bad things going
on and in communist systems there was
none and so it was easy to imagine that
they were great systems so people who
had come from a communist side in China
and they were trying to convince others
that wait a minute no you don't want
this type of totalitarian system in your
life you don't want to bring it there
they would talk and talk and talk and it
made no difference at all because the
people couldn't imagine what kind of
experiences there were it's the same for
the Jews during the Holocaust I mean
people just didn't believe what was
going on so sometimes it's just it's
hard to imagine how you can change a
person because you really can't unless
they're experiencing the kinds of things
that you've seen and you've encountered
but at the same time it's important to
be aware that your own good intentions
can also
lead you astray so what do I mean by
that there was a wonderful study done
published in the 1970s by John McCord
and what she did was she she went back
and looked at an old study in the 1930s
of Boston school boys 500 Nootka they
split them into two groups one was the
control group they did nothing to him
the other group was given every possible
advantage they they had counseling
summer camps they got extra tutoring it
just a medical assistance even
assistance for the family it was really
about the best you could imagine 30
years later John McCord followed up on
those two groups one group had
significantly higher rates of suicide
alcoholism drug use they were in jail
more they ended up in lower-class jobs I
mean it was just sort of every sort of
bad thing you could imagine they had
significantly higher proportions of
people who had this kind of thing
happened to them and which group was
that it was the group they caught all
the help and what was interesting was
that the people involved in the study
were convinced that they weren't helping
that group but it backfired and it was
only when they they really went in and
looked carefully at the data that they
found that this wonderful helping was
making the researchers and the
participants feel very good but it was
actually harming the boys that they
wanted to help so some of my research
involves pathologies of altruism and
that is sort of this road to hell is
sometimes paved by good intentions it's
it's very important to be aware that
sometimes you can be totally convinced
that you are helping and that what
you're doing is the right and good thing
for others and unless you're willing to
sort of
let that stand up to scientific scrutiny
you you just be surprised at how you are
sometimes incorrect and there are other
ways to help that are maybe not so
obvious and maybe don't make you feel so
good but actually that truly help
[Music]
you